so just in case you thought we haven't
been ambitious enough in our coverage so
far we're going to end the morning with
the discussion on the question of how
will a I change the world so to moderate
that we have the brave Lila Janna who is
the founder of samasource and I'd like
to introduce her and her panelists
please so we have Joel macchia who's an
economic historian from Northwestern
University Jewell Raziq who is the
president of the International
Association of universities we have
Cynthia Brazell from the MIT Media Lab
and also the founder of Gebo Inc social
robotics company and Michael Leavitt
who's the 2013 Nobel laureate in
chemistry from Stanford University
I recognize that we're the panel just
before lunch so we're going to try to
keep this very lively and interesting
and make it a conversation most of the
discussion around AI focuses on how it
pushes the boundary on innovation and
technological progress
I would love us to talk about how it
affects people living at the bottom of
the pyramid people who are not wearing
Apple watches people who are not working
for unicorns in places like Silicon
Valley or Sweden let's talk about how
these advances will impact them and
Michael let's start with you and I
apologize in advance we're going to try
to keep our remarks to a minute or so so
I apologize in advance for possibly
interrupting a Nobel laureate so in
keeping with the likeness I wanted to
start with a joke I heard recently from
my daughter-in-law this is a list for
the school trip which could be at any
school in the world right now camera not
needed it's on the smartphone torch not
needed so your smartphone compass not
needed on your smartphone map music
alarm clock games newspapers guidebooks
television finally a good mood not
needed because everyone is very in their
smartphone so what is needed a charger I
think
has changed the world I'm done that's a
great point Joey you had you had similar
comments this morning yeah I mean we
talked a great deal about inequality in
this world and every comma mist which
recognizes how bad it is but we also
have to understand and in some ways
technology is a great equalizer and that
in that regard very few things have
changed the developing world as much as
the cell phone because the cell phone
allowed it allowed people to build
networks of communication without the
expensive infrastructure of setting up
an landline phone system and the way
cell phones have changed places like
Africa or southern Asia is impossible to
imagine for somebody living in the
developed world because they are
everywhere people do banking people find
jobs people find employees people find
plumbers everything is done on a cell
phone and in that regard it's really we
all really should think long and hard
about how much technology is an
equalizing factor not only between
developing and under developing
countries but you know the news is you
know that they're the richest man in
America or the second richest men as
somebody called sheldon adel stone he
and i have exactly the same smartphone
and there is nothing that he can do in
spending twenty eight million dollars to
get a better smartphone we have the same
smartphone technology is a great
equalizer of both within countries and
between countries and in that regard i
am a great optimist because as i see
technology going forward i see many of
the gaps not all unfortunately but many
of the gaps between rich and poor slowly
shrinking and that is the best news i
think of the essentially so you work
with professors across the developing
world do you agree with the statement i
mean we still have millions of people
who don't have access to electricity at
home
who don't have access to highest
bandwidth or smartphones tell us what
you think well III think it is a
question of how it changes depending on
what conditions are we talking about I
want to go back to what Gandhi used to
say what he calls the seven social
blunders that we need to be mindful of
three of which i think is related to
discussion today one it's when he says
we do we do science without humanity as
we escalate humanity using science it's
I'm concerned about the livelihood of
people at large we are not talking about
just a group of persons we are talking a
whole population what we call the bottom
billions are the affected by science
without humanity the second issue is
perhaps knowledge without wisdom the
earlier panel talked about with them and
I like the word they need to be factored
in when we talk about technology where
is wisdom is this all this technology we
may have knowledge but this wisdom
embedded in that technology at the same
time and is certainly an issue that is
very lated to AI in in this particular
context and last but not least as we see
more science being funded by private
sector the whole issue of business
winner affects the outcome or the goal
of science and the goal of business may
not necessarily be the same and
therefore we want to know whether
effects do influence the way science
develop depending on the funding
depending on the kind of negotiation
that we do at the same time so in the
developing countries we discuss this
quite a lot example when we talk about
science without ethics this year we
celebrate the 70th anniversary of the
explosion of the atomic bomb in
Hiroshima and Nagasaki there is already
a question for us where is humanity when
we develop that particular bomb and how
come it is repeated twice one in
Hiroshima and one in Agra sake what
happened to science at that particular
point in time we'll talk about knowledge
with wisdom the whole idea of climate
change and global warming the cop21 is
there a disconnect between science and
wisdom at a particular point is
something that the question that we need
to ask so these are issues that I think
which is important I'm gonna I think
this is a great transition into
Cynthia's work she's known mostly as
robot assist but we were talking a
little bit about her work on education
I'd like to restrict my comments to
thinking about a profound positive
impact that AI can have particularly we
speak about education for all and I just
wanted to highlight one particular
project because I think it brings it all
into two-color we know that personal
tutoring is much more effective for
learning outcomes than the sort of
lecture hall style of information and
with AI with the ability to track how
children engage with digital materials
we have a eyes that can create
personalized models in terms of
understanding what children understand
what do they understand what is that
point of information or knowledge
they're on the cusp of understanding so
you can start to deliver a highly
personalized learning experience so
right now I'm involved in a project
called the curious learning initiative
that involves multiple institutions
where we are creating an open platform
and a platform for education
specifically for the most
under-resourced children because of the
proliferation of Technology of the
affordability of the scalability we're
actually able to deploy and study these
systems in the most extreme learning
situations we're talking about villages
in Ethiopia so far from schools that the
children can't go to school we're
talking about school classes in South
Africa where the student to teacher
ratio is 80 to 100 or even in
impoverished areas in the United States
we're not every child can go to
preschool because they don't have enough
preschool sites it's done by lottery
we've been studying how this technology
can be deployed in these systems with
extremely positive results for for us
the killer app right now is literacy so
we think about the spreading of the
internet and technology literacy is
really becoming critical and education
is absolutely becoming as much of a
fundamental right as food clothing and
shelter so a lot of opportunity here and
I think all of the technological trends
we now have a corpus of children
learning with this technology across all
of these countries that we can learn how
they engage with this technology how
they learned in these different contexts
so huge wealth of scientific opportunity
as well and what we're finding is it's a
highly social process it's not the case
of children with their nose and a tablet
they're sharing they're talking it's
children bringing natural learning
processes supported by technology in a
way that's leading to positive learning
outcomes why you see huge
huge tremendous potential for education
for all with with a I I'd like us to to
talk a little bit about this issue of
science and empathy Michael you're a
scientist how do you think we should
think about empathy in the scientific
context and especially as we're as we're
developing some of these new systems you
know in Silicon Valley we tend to think
about the bottom line or increasing
innovation empathy doesn't usually
factor into those discussions very early
on in the process so I would say that
I'm going to talk about this not a lot
of Silicon Valley is applied science I'm
gonna think about this in terms of basic
science and I think my guess is that
many many basic sciences the successful
ones pretty much maybe not autistic but
not necessarily socially very skilled
being a geek really makes a difference
essentially if we focus on something
which you could hope you can't hardly
explain to anybody and if you did they
wouldn't really be at all interested so
in some senses in basic science you're
out there on the frontier picking away
for bits of information that make no
sense at all when you get them I think
in my case I'm probably super autistic
but I got married when I was 20 and now
I have six grandchildren and a wife and
three children that made a huge
difference but I do think that this is
one of the problems that very often a
basic scientist can't even say when it's
going to be good for he doesn't know and
I think we have to realize and this goes
back to what you were saying a lot of
the ethics here comes from thinking you
know what's going to happen but if you
look at this so many things that have
happened happen in an unexpected way
maybe the trends are predictable but
exactly what happens the extremely
unexpected I think that I think actually
basic science is there also in the world
there's been a big move away from basic
science so most countries are not
talking about translational research
applied research and that's very
dangerous because if you know where
you're going you're not going to find
something really interesting and
someone's you've got to say to somebody
go ahead and do something that no one
really understands and finds it so I
think the empathy is an employee's a
company at issue
and
I don't even know how apathetic I and my
wife would probably say very not
empathetic that's why I have a wife at
least you're self-aware would anybody
else like to comment on that not on
Michaels empathy or lack thereof but on
the general topic I think there is an
active dialogue going on now so I I'm an
innovator I create technologies but
really around what are the values of
humanistic values that we apply when we
create these technologies and I think as
we understand now that we have super
computers in our pockets and so forth
really trying to understand how can
these systems to be deployed in a way
how can they be designed in a way that
really promotes human flourishing really
to think beyond the kind of efficacy in
the utility to really think about how it
impacts real people's lives versus the
few specialists or scientists or whatnot
to really think about everyone and I
hear much more of that open dialogue
happening now which i think is
absolutely critical so you know as an
economist you always worry about one
thing and that is that much of the
direction in which science and
technology are going are determined by
market forces and they're a real
question that we really have to ask
ourselves is do we really wish to rely
on what markets decide in terms of where
science and technology are going and
they're very good reasons to think that
that may not be the case that and this
is the classic case in which markets
needs nudging from politicians from
public opinions from people outside the
market selasa first Exorcist
and so on and so forth and so weary it
really matters that a lot of research
should go into things like malaria
schistosomiasis and diseases like that
and affect millions of people in poor
countries rather than on the research on
Botox for you know wealthy American
women but that is unfortunately where a
lot of money is
or impotence drugs for wealthy American
men to be to shake but the main point is
that I said it with some regret because
I'm an economist and roughly speaking
I'm trained to believe in markets but
it's important to be able to step aside
and say in this particular case we
should not rely on market and then the
question of course is well who should we
rely on and unfortunately I think the
quality of our public servants
particularly I'm afraid United States
these days hasn't always lived up to the
expectations that we need to supplement
the market and so we have really the
choice between two rather and attractive
alternatives one of them is the markets
dictum with a you know backed up by
money and the other is politicians who
are worrying about votes and neither of
those unfortunately are perfect and so
we will not get the best of all possible
worlds ladies and gentlemen we'll just
muddle through some pessimism from the
art from the tech optimists this is
surprising so I think the question that
was raised was very relevant to to
developing countries that you want to do
science the kinds of science that we do
normally comes in from what the
developed country does we always look at
what is quote unquote current in the
world at large and we try to imitate
them you know sometimes resources are a
big problem
as you can see malaria dysentery
diarrhea these are age-old diseases
which is still proliferating in many
developing countries you know and I'm so
happy that the Nobel laureate for for
physic Physiology and medicine this year
goes to a person to work on a team in
artemisinin a natural product that comes
from herbs for malaria control I mean
these are the kind of research letting
this relevant cotton code for developing
countries to move ahead unless we get
this done technology will be secondary
to us I also add that there are new
models of fundraising that are happening
now crowdfunding being one of them
right now people as individuals can kind
of vote with their pocketbook in terms
of what projects they deemed to be
interesting and important and it often
gives young startups the bill or
nonprofits to kind of get a foothold
going and then hopefully they can scale
and raise the money from there so this
is a space that I do think needs a lot
of innovation but I think democratizing
that process is one potential step
that's that's helping we have a question
from the audience this is taking the
conversation in a slightly different
direction but perhaps we can end on this
more funny note will a I make people
lazy Michael so I you know people before
stood the gps's would make us unable to
travel nothing quite the reverse I
really like learning new ways to go to
places and I don't see any reason why I
actually make us lazy I think that smart
phones are actually quite stimulating
and you know I think that we might I
mean a bigger dangerous to get by a car
while you cross the road to an email but
you know otherwise I don't think so an
economist I do not recognize words like
lazy
I only know leisure preference the fact
of the matter is that in my lifetime and
gives you an idea of how long we've been
around it was one of the revolutionary
changes were introduced we're
calculating machine I'm not talking
computers I'm just basically machine and
allows you to multiply divide add and
subtract and people always said well if
you introduce machines will people not
lose their knowledge of erasmus ik and
now we have computers that allow us to
run regressions and dukkha and do
computer program programming and so so
don't we lose the ability to think and
the answer is no I don't think AI makes
us lazy what AI will do it will take our
energies and channel them in more
productive more effective directions
because somebody's gonna do the grudge
work for us that I think is a big step
forward
scenery doesn't make people lazy it just
redirects their energy usually in more
productive ways in that sense I am a
great optimist in that sense I really
feel but who directs is an issue I mean
we talk about hand phones smart phones
fine but there was a study that shows
you know in a particular country there's
more people who have hand phones than
public toilets so public solid is still
an issue in that particular country but
then there are a lot of people with hand
phones so we don't see the balance at
all it's where technology is taking
that's where the basic human needs are
not even taking into account as far as
technology is concerned so I mean I I
agree that the opportunity is the
affordability and scalability of
technology that hopefully over time that
will correct itself and I do think it
needs to be an intentional design choice
as we create these technologies to make
sure again they support our human values
and I do think people are inherently
we're curious we seek out meaning in our
lives I don't think it's gonna make us
lazy I think we are driven by these
things that lead to a rich fulfilling
life and I think we will leverage these
technologies to facilitate our ability
to do so great so I will ask us to end
with just one line kind of summary of
your view on how a I will impact
humanity and think of it in terms of a
tweet so maybe a hundred and forty
characters max I'm not a tweeter but I
would just say that technology is a
great opportunity just go with it I
would say that technology needs to be
intentionally designed to promote human
flourishing
I would agree also that but needs to be
balanced where the human concentration
becomes an important issue and for all
of those who think that the low-hanging
fruits of Technology have been picked
and that we've made all the easy
invention and now it gets harder and
harder my prediction is you ain't seen
nothing yet
thank you so much